[Música]
era un hombre hablador sus palabras eran
técnicas a menudo excéntrica a veces
incomprensibles pero nunca aburridas
también fue una enigmática figura a la
que nada le gustaba más que preguntar y
hacerse preguntas
desde que me hice una lista de preguntas
voy a mostrar la lista que está escrita
en hebreo aquí está esta es mi lista y
entonces me pregunté es que no noto en
nuestra industria actual es que a la
plaza pues no hay espacio para las
necesidades y la inclusión o ambas están
enfrentadas es que yo soy para existir
lo poco que hay que provocar te metemos
la normalidad está pasada de moda
ser normal es algo un poco decadente es
que la realidad sólo existe a modo de
reality show de reality show o la
realidad es también nuestra vida
es que
es la uniformidad lo nuevo del sol
la individualidad sigue siendo
importante en portón
alber elbaz diseñador de moda estilista
falleció el 24 de abril de 2021 a los 59
años murió de un infarto tras haberse
contagiado de kobe
[Música]
creo que el mundo de la moda lo ama
porque él mismo es irresistible es un
personaje totalmente irresistible albert
liberó a las mujeres para que sean las
mujeres que quieran ser para que se
sientan más cómodas con sus prendas para
que sean más felices con sus prendas
para que se inspiren en sí mismas y en
la vida entiende totalmente lo que
muchas mujeres quieren ponerse
albergue el baas nació en casablanca en
1961 fue criado en israel se graduó en
el encar college de tel-aviv y continuó
sus estudios en eeuu llegó a francia en
1996 para convertirse en director
artístico de guy lagos un año más tarde
viejo rey él lo puso al frente del prêt
à porter de ir salón allí permaneció dos
años pero luego salió de allí cuando la
marca fue comprada por el grupo que en
2001 la empresaria taiwanesas autlán
wang le compró al grupo l'oréal la más
antigua casa de moda francesa blandine
puso alber elbaz al frente de ésta quien
se quedó 14 años allí revelando su
visión de una feminidad conquistadora
sexy y moderna
todos los materiales eran telas de
sujetadores y si mis vestidos
voluminosos apelantes con cortes como de
buceo
pero todos al estilo de la alta costura
el cuchillo
alber elbaz siempre le gustó trabajar
con distintos materiales tanto para la
ropa como para los accesorios en febrero
de 2014 para la colección de moda
masculina de landing ecodiseño con lucas
ossendrijver trío zapatillas deportivas
en tercios
ante cuero cuero volteado pintado o
pulido en piel de terneros serpiente o
tiburón zapatos es una mezcla de todo
quizás sean zapatos que también sus
zapatillas deportivas atléticas pero con
colores que son digitales los zapatos
son como botas pero la base de scouts me
la pasé a un caucho
en 2010 albergue elvas y blandín
lanzaron una colección a precios bajos
en colaboración con el gigante sueco de
la moda rápida y tenemos igual que lo
hicieron antes karl lagerfeld y sonia
rykiel democratizar la moda era uno de
sus sueños
el logo de la band es una madre con su
hija
dos generaciones es algo que también
promovemos aquí
para democratizar la compra en nuestras
prendas por eso me encanta la idea de
que la abuela la madre y la nieta se
pongan los mismos vestidos pero en 2015
hubo un cambio repentino alber elbaz
cuestiona las decisiones estratégicas de
la propietaria de la marca su salida de
la casa provocó una conmoción en el
mundo de la moda en 14 años había creado
un estilo un aspecto un chic francés que
había restaurado el prestigio y las
finanzas de la centenaria casa parisina
no fue hasta finales de 2019 que pudo
volver a lanzar un gran proyecto con el
grupo de lujo suizo richemont acy
factory se trataba de un nuevo comienzo
que él explica con la brillantez de un
narrador excepcional en un vídeo
publicado en enero de 2021 a la que fue
a la moda pero no era industria de la
moda
estuve viajando por todo el mundo además
después de este viaje me pregunte can
tradition and puede coexistir la
tradición de la tecnología esta sigue
siendo relevante la moda hoy en día y
saben que la respuesta es sí
que deseaba vestir a todas las mujeres
de todas las edades de todas las
morfologías con las mismas prendas como
con telas técnicas en lycra de alta gama
[Música]
y en los pies zapatillas de deporte
puntiagudas
y como el confinamiento hizo que la
comodidad fuera casi obligatoria y ya
más de exterior sin olvidar el vestido
negro o no
dotado de una cremallera en la espalda
como en los trajes de buceo era el sueño
hecho realidad era mi sueño hecho
realidad gracias por su apoyo y bueno
espero que les guste este proyecto
espero que les guste nuestra ropa
tenemos que darle la voz para que sean
ustedes mismas judy voice tv para que
sea amén y nosotros estamos aquí a su
lado
gracias por formar parte de mí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
este talentoso visionario planeaba
vender sus nuevos productos en
plataformas en línea no en tiendas
albergue el baas ahora descansa en paz
en israel no lejos de sus padres